dorothée bonsoir bonsoir qu'elle est
qu'est ce que vous journalistes ne te
poses ans le plus souvent c'est pas très
bien habillée comme ça la question 'qui
vous êtes star des enfants et pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas d'enfant vous même tu la
connais bien cette question et tu penses
tu que nous tendent à dorian autant avec
ça si tu étais un homme
je crois que oui est ce que tu crois que
le succès que tu as auprès des enfants
se consolent des méchants c'est que l'on
dit sur toi ou nous parce que les
méchancetés sont toujours dures à avaler
à digérer mais cela dit quand on quand
on parle avec les enfants qu'il vous
donne des critiques plus ou moins gentil
agressive on sait qu'elles sont vraies
donc on les accepte plus facilement
alors que celle des adultes on sait pas
trop d'où elles viennent tuer pour ou
contre les ficelles pour quand c'est
bien nommé mais quoique non contre et
as-tu déjà à gifler un enfant jamais
mais si tu continues
peut-être que je vais pour toi qu'est-ce
qu'il est plus violent pour un enfant
puis jalons pour un enfant je crois que
c'est ne pas avoir d'amour d'un amour de
ses parents de ses frères et soeurs de
ses copains si les parents sont toujours
as-tu déjà reçu une lettre de gens
désespérés qui voulait te confier leurs
enfants des lettres non mais j'avoue
qu'un jour lors d'une dédicace
il ya une jeune fille qui est arrivé en
disant j'ai mon bébé dans les bras là
bas dans les bras et il me dit je peux
faire une photo bien sûr je prends la
des pitchouns et photographes ou la
photo et la maman partait elle me le
confiait donc on a récupéré la rendu son
enfant d un coup excuse moi mais tu es
la maman c'est ton enfant tu t'en
occupes et servait normal mais j'ai eu
très très peur
imaginons on sait jamais tu est nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale non
d'accord imaginons tube est nommé
ministre de l'éducation nationale donc
qu'est-ce que tu ferais mais je me dis
ministre si tu avais un enfant tu
emmènerait ou pour le distraire
à ton émission ou pour le punir
peut-être à l'émission d'ardisson parce
qu elle se définit
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus